ception et ma tristesse
bien que nous ayons été des millions à
vouloir en finir avec le quinquennat
d'emmanuel macron ce soir les amoureux
de la france au perdu et emmanuel macron
a été réélu aisément il est le premier
président à avoir été réélu sans sortir
d'une période de cohabitation et alors
même que sa personne faisait l'objet
d'un rejet massif par nos compatriotes
son duel avec marine le pen était
présenté comme la revanche de celui de
2017 mais la revanche annoncée a tourné
court
cela fait trop longtemps
que ceux qui aiment passionnément la
france sont vaincus cela fait trop
longtemps que ceux qui veulent défendre
son identité et mettre un terme à
l'immigration sont amèrement déçu un
soir d'élection
hélas hélas hélas c'est la huitième fois
que la défaite frappe le nom de le pen
je voyais cette défaite venir depuis des
années et ce n'est vraiment pas de
gaieté de coeur que je l'annonçais j'ai
fait ce que j'ai pu pour éviter ce
résultat je me suis engagé pour cela je
n'y suis pas parvenu en appelant sans
tergiverser dès le soir du premier tour
à voter pour marine le pen jeu
encore pour me tromper
malheureusement pour la france
malheureusement pour les français c'est
bien emmanuel macron qui a été élu
sommes nous donc condamné à perm y at il
une fatalité pour que les idées
nationales perdent toutes les élections
alors qu'une majorité de notre peuple
souhaite ardemment que la france reste
de la france
non je veux dire ce soir qu'il n'y a pas
de fatalité
nous avons des raisons d'espérer
notre parti reconquête est fort de cette
jeunesse cette belle jeunesse militante
est si enthousiaste
note
notre parti reconquête efforts de ses
122 mille adhérents et je remercie ceux
qui continuent de nous rejoindre chaque
jour
il est fort de ces milliers de cadres
partout en france fort de ses talents de
sa créativité de ses compétences nous
serons donc à la pointe du combat pour
lutter pied à pied contre l'oeuvre de
déconstruction de notre pays menés par
emmanuel macron nous combattrons pour
nos idées dans chaque ville et dans
chaque village de france sur internet et
dans les médias
[Musique]
mais il ne peut y avoir de victoire
électorale sens alliance entre toutes
les droites entre les classes populaires
et la bourgeoisie patriotes entre les
grands parents et leurs petits enfants
entre la france périphérique et les
habitants des métropoles qu'ils veulent
continuer de vivre dans une france
française
situation politique d'aujourd'hui nous
impose d'agir les élections législatives
qui viennent en juin prochain voit déjà
la constitution de deux grands blocs
politiques autour d' emmanuel macron et
d'auchan luc mélenchon deux blocs l'un
macro nice l'autre islamo-gauchiste deux
blocs qui s'organise se rassemblent et
s'apprêtent à s'affronter dans un match
qui n'aura à coup sûr qu'un seul perdant
la france le camp national serait-il
donc le seul à ne pas être capable de
s'unir voulons nous donner les pleins
pouvoirs à emmanuel macron et jean luc
mélenchon
je ne le veux pas nous sommes des
millions à ne pas le vouloir le bloc
national doit lui aussi s'unir et se
rassembler notre responsabilité est
immense
c'est pour cela que j'appelle à l'union
nationale en vue des législatives
nous devons oublier nos querelles et
unir nos forces c'est possible c'est
indispensable
c'est notre devoir
pâtissons au plus vite la première
coalition des droites et des patriotes
pour que les élus de reconquête du
rassemblement national de debout la
france et ceux des républicains qui ne
veulent pas se rallier à emmanuel macron
est une chance de peser voire de dominer
dans la prochaine assemblée
notre coalition n'est pas une option
elle est une nécessité
elle est un devoir nous avons un pays à
reconquérir l'union fait la force notre
coalition doit faire la france vive la
république et surtout surtout vive la
poste
eric zemmour qui vient de d'appeler à
l'union des droites et
[Musique]